Rolling Stone has officially released
its list of the 200 greatest singers of
all time leaving some fans outrageous
I just gotta laugh I just gotta laugh
yeah near far wherever you are there's
some serious anger over the fact that
Canadians own Celine Dion was not
included in the top 200. that's right
published on New Year's Day artists like
Kelly Clarkson Michael Jackson Frank
Ocean and Beyonce all made the list but
Celine was absent meanwhile Aretha
Franklin took the top spot ahead of
Whitney Houston and Sam Cooke in second
and third places among the outrage from
fans online on one Twitter user rights
any greatest singers list that doesn't
include Celine Dion is simply wrong LMAO
there was no discussion to be had I like
this one another user adds shame on
Rolling Stones uh Celine Dion is one of
the best singers to ever pick up a mic
she deserves better yeah now there were
also complaints that other singers like
Dionne Warwick Diana Ross and sting were
not included Carlos what are your
thoughts are you upset what I mean are
you feeling this are you feeling this
Vibe I mean I'm too chilled out from
holidays to feel any real outrage but I
do understand if you're gonna have have
a list of the greatest yeah
how do you miss Celine Dion I mean it's
always going to be a difficult
proposition to say here's the top 200
Top 100 whatever singers ever but I mean
there's a thing that people got to
understand about this too one of the
whole reasons that you do this is to get
people talking yeah
number 200 that could have been a
discussion right there she has to be on
the list this is completely wrong I am
outraged by this even Mia didn't make
the list
you would like people would be upset
that she wasn't United like you gotta
you gotta please her this is the weird
the weirdest thing about this whole
thing to me with regards to Celine Dion
is that it's like they just completely
forgot they forgot like what is how what
is the reason that you leave her off a
list if you consider her as a singer you
know she goes in the top whatever like
she's in she's right after Whitney use
your arm maybe even with Whitney Houston
I don't know can you have two people at
two or is she a number two and Whitney's
number and this is where you get into
that right but she needs to be in the
top ten so lean Dion needs to be in the
top ten they need to change the list
they made a mistake it's okay to say and
come out and say I'm sorry we made a
mistake with Celine Dion That's right
maybe there's maybe they're just holding
back for another list
of just Celine Dion like I don't know I
don't know don't fix it man you gotta
fix it